Você sabia que aquela xícara de chá,
pedaço de chocolate amargo, pode estar
baixando sua pressão arterial? Pois é,
um estudo gigante com mais de 5.000
pessoas mostrou que os flavonoides
presentes no chá verde, chá preto,
chocolate amargo, maçãs e frutas
vermelhas conseguem reduzir a pressão em
até seis a sete pontos para quem tem
hipertensão. Isso é quase o efeito de um
remédio, viu? Veja bem, esses compostos
chamados Flav 3óis trabalham dilatando
os vasos sanguíneos e melhorando a
circulação. É como se fosse um vaso
dilatador natural que você já tem na sua
casa. Duas a três xícaras de chá por dia
ou um quadradinho de chocolate 70% de
cacau já faz a diferença. Então, na
próxima vez que for tomar o seu chá da
tarde, lembra que você tá cuidando do
seu coração também. Experimenta trocar
aquele doce por uma maçã e me conta se
sentiu diferença.